Well,
I'd like to welcome the,
uh,
prospective students.
Uh,
hi.
I won't say the word Yaley prematurely,
but I of course,
I hope you all come.
And,
uh,
I wish I had a chance to provide a little context for what I'm going to say
today,
but,
uh,
maybe we'll scramble into some sense of things as we go along.
Uh,
this,
this lecture,
uh,
concerns,
an essay,
uh,
written to immediate a widespread acclaim and controversy by two young at the
time quite an influential and untenured scholars trying to make their way in the
world.
Um,
they certainly succeeded with this,
with this essay which was published in critical inquiry then certainly the
leading,
uh,
Oregon for the dissemination of innovative theoretical ideas.
And they were,
um,
uh,
generally speaking,
gratified by the results.
Almost immediately the editors of critical inquiry decided to publish together
with,
against theory in book form,
decided to publish a series of responses to against theory.
All of them thought of polite,
uh,
careful a thought through responses,
which made it very interesting thin book,
uh,
which,
which is,
is still available.
I think it's still in print.
Um,
and well worth having if you take an interest in the controversies that the,
that the article generated.
And of course I'm hoping,
uh,
in the time remaining to get you to take an interest in them.
Uh,
now been,
Michael's were then still are a what's called neo pragmatists,
which is to say,
um,
they are influenced most immediately by an important book,
uh,
written in the 1970s by the philosopher Richard Rorty called philosophy and the
mirror of nature.
Uh,
but,
but roared,
he riding in a tradition that goes back through the important work of John Dewey
in the 1930s and forties.
And before then,
uh,
not only to the Great Philosophical Interventions of William James Henry James,
his brother,
uh,
but also a theory of signs by Charles Sanders purse,
um,
uh,
theory,
PE I our CE a theory,
which at the time,
uh,
didn't generate,
too much recognition or controversy.
It was taken up by the so called Cambridge School of literary critics headed by
a Richards,
he and Ck Ogden road,
some reflections on purses,
semiotics.
But today with pragmatism,
neo pragmatism,
uh,
a fairly important strain in academic,
theoretical and literary,
uh,
persons semiotics is inner way receiving more attention.
Uh,
in a way it's in a way also challenging the head Germany in the field of
literary theory of so sewers,
semiotics,
this sense of the sign as something different from what so Sarah said it was,
is going to be the underlying theme of the central.
The second and central part of of this lecture 1982 was probably the high
watermark,
both of the fascination and the frustration with literary theory in this
country.
It was a hot button topic.
Uh,
we've gone into this before in ways that it is not really today that are our
interest in literary theory as at least in part historical one might want to
say,
uh,
in 1982 though,
where you stood on these matters just made all the difference and it was in that
atmosphere that nap and Michael's is against theory,
uh,
was published.
Now as I say,
they were neo pragmatist.
And what that means basically is that one knows things,
which is the same thing as to say that one believes things,
one act in the world unhesitatingly as an agent.
It all sort of everything that matters in being human has to do with one's
powers of agency,
but that there are no actual foundations in what we can know objectively for our
beliefs and actions.
In other words,
it's a physician,
uh,
which is called [inaudible] or Antifa [inaudible] list,
but not a position that as such a position might imply,
uh,
somehow entails Neil ism or are kind of crippling radical skepticism.
Uh,
on the contrary,
it's a position that insists that we just do what we do,
that we are always doing thinking,
believing,
saying something that we are always,
uh,
exerting an influence,
um,
as social beings and our surroundings.
Uh,
and that the only thing that needn't concern us about our powers of agency is
that perhaps we don't really have a full,
adequate,
an objective account of how and why it is that we do and say and believe and
influence things in the way that we do.
So that the,
that,
that position is essentially the position taken up in Napa and Michael's now you
saw it last time already,
uh,
in the essay of Stanley fish,
Stanley fish who takes it,
that we are largely produced by the interpretive community to which we belong,
uh,
his understanding of this community as that which constitutes our values.
In other words,
nothing intrinsic to ourselves.
Uh,
nothing unique in our own modes of perception,
but rather the ways in which our educational circumstances,
uh,
bring us to believe and understand things.
This too is a neo pragmatist position.
Now you notice that in the third part of the not nap and Michael's essay,
uh,
they engage in a kind of polite disagreement with fish.
Uh,
they are under the,
there is an underlying,
very broad disagreement with him.
But remember in the third part of the essay they're talking about the synonym
Mitie the identity of knowledge and belief.
And they point to a particular passage in one of fishes arguments where he kind
of slipped in to the idea that on the one hand you have knowledge and then the
on the other hand you have in relation to that knowledge,
uh,
belief.
And they say,
no,
no.
You can't separate knowledge and belief.
Um,
and just on those grounds they disagree with fish and fish writes one of the
responses,
uh,
in the book.
This then subsequently published concerning against theory,
but it's a completely friendly controversy about,
uh,
about,
a transitory and superficial matter.
And as a matter of fact,
while I'm going to pay a lot of attention to the first two arguments there,
they're basically three arguments in this essay.
I'm going to pay very little attention to the third argument,
which fishes engaged about the relationship between knowledge and belief.
Um,
in part at least because it's an argument that does belong to philosophy.
Uh,
it is the cornerstone of roared.
He's argument in philosophy in the mirror of nature and uh,
that perhaps not so immediately relevant,
uh,
to the kinds of things that we think about in doing literary theory.
So to turn then to,
uh,
what they actually do say,
at in relation to this movement that I'm talking about.
You notice for example,
that in tone their work is very similar to that a Stanley fish.
Uh,
it's a kind of a downright,
uh,
no nonsense.
Um,
let's get on with it kind of tone that after reading,
you know,
dairy gone and,
and,
and other writers of that kind,
uh,
you're perhaps not quite ready for it.
Oh yeah.
Pros can be like that too.
Um,
and in a way it's bracing.
I mean,
it,
it must be kind of a relief,
um,
uh,
to get these,
this sort of no nonsense attitude toward these issues after all the tacking and
varying that we're likely to have experienced,
uh,
in earlier writers.
So the tone,
in a way,
the tone comes with the territory.
You take these views and in a way the tone seems to follow it from it because
what they're saying is,
you know,
you just do what you do.
You think what you think as a literary interpreter,
you're bound to have some opinion about what you're looking at it.
So just get on with it,
express that opinion,
and that's your job of work.
The only way you can go wrong on this view and in this tone,
the only way you can go wrong is to grope around for some theoretical
justification for what you're doing.
It's just fine that you're doing it.
Don't worry about it,
get on with it,
but don't think,
uh,
according to the argument of nap and Michael's that you can hope to find
anything like,
uh,
an underlying or broad theoretical justification for what you're doing.
Obviously that rather challenging and provocative notion is something that lends
itself readily to the sort of no nonsense tone that I'm talking about.
Okay.
So turning then to,
to their argument,
they are,
they,
they argue that people become entangled with issues of theory,
all of which in their view should be avoided when they do too,
when that,
well,
three.
But as I say,
we're going to set knowledge and belief aside when they make three fundamental
mistakes.
And the first,
uh,
is to suppose that there's a difference between meaning.
In other words,
for example,
to know a meaning,
you have to be able to invoke an intention on the one hand or,
uh,
in the absence of an intention.
Uh,
we cannot possibly speak of a meaning.
On the other hand,
that's their first argument.
People get become embroiled in theory when they make one of those two mistakes.
And we'll come back to that in a minute.
The second argument is,
uh,
the insistence that there's no such thing as a difference between language and
speech.
In other words,
the so Syria and idea that we have language somehow or another virtually present
in our heads as a lexicon at a set of rules of grammar and syntax and that that
language long producers speech.
What I say from sentence to sentence,
Paul,
that this notion is simply false because there is no difference between language
and speech.
That's their,
that's their second premise.
Now,
before I launch into those arguments,
let me say one more thing about their attitude toward theory.
Let me call your attention to the very first paragraph,
which,
uh,
in your pamphlet is on page oh 79,
the very first paragraph of against theory where interestingly they exempt
certain ways of thinking about literature,
certain cuase I scientific ways of thinking about literature from their charge
against theory.
They say the term theory is sometimes applied to literary subjects with no
direct bearing on the interpretation of individual works,
such as narrow totology,
stylistics and proximity despite their generality.
However,
these subjects seem to us essentially empirical and our arguments against the
theory will not apply to them.
Well,
not,
this is a little surprising because I mean for one thing and this course,
which is presumably devoted to theory,
we've talked about some of these things,
especially about narrow tology stylistics,
which is,
um,
you know,
the,
the science of style and how one can approach dial syntactically statistically
and in a variety of ways,
uh,
in which that's done.
And poetics,
which is general ideas about what constitutes a poem or a text written in some
other genre,
um,
which,
which all of which,
for example,
must remind us very much of the Russian formalists,
uh,
narrow tology as we studied it.
It's largely derived from structuralism indeed.
Also from certain ideas of Freud.
And all of this sounds suspiciously like theory.
What point are they making about it?
Well,
simply the point that those ways of thinking about literature,
which they exempt from their diatribe against theory,
are the ways that they call empirical ways of thinking about literature that are
based on observation.
And that of course would certainly,
it seems to me apply to the Russian formalists at least what the Russian
formalists think.
They're doing a ways that are empirical in the sense that they observe data,
they build up a kind of database and they generalize from what they have
observed.
They begin,
in other words with the object in question,
uh,
and then draw conclusions from it.
So empirical approaches to literature,
the simple observation of data for which one can generalize,
uh,
they exempt from the general charge against literary theory.
All right.
Turning then to the idea that intention and meaning just must be the same thing.
Uh,
and then subsequently the idea that language and speech just must be the same
thing
in the background.
I'd like you to be thinking about some of the implications of this sentence by
Stanley Cavell,
which was written in another one of the responses to this essay that was
published in the book against theory.
I don't want to reflect on it now.
Um,
but,
um,
it's,
uh,
it saves to me,
um,
uh,
a strikingly vivid way of posing a challenge to the nap and Michael position,
which,
um,
in a variety of ways,
uh,
if only by implication will be touching on,
all right,
so what do nap and Michael's do in order to convince us?
And I'm,
and I'm going to be going a long way with them here,
uh,
in,
in almost all the way,
even though I'm going to be taking a sharp turning toward the end of the road,
which I hope saves theory.
I mean,
after all,
I,
it it,
it,
it's scarcely conscionable to stand here,
uh,
sort of 26 times in front of you for an hour each and then finally to confess at
the end that the thing we've been talking about should be banished from our
vocabulary.
And so,
so,
so needless to say,
it's incumbent on me to save our subject matter.
I will,
but you're going to have to wait a while because as I say,
I am going to be going a long way down the road with nap and Michael's now
Michael said,
well,
you know what the thing about the way in which we,
we,
we approach any text,
any utterance,
any instance of language floating before us is just to take for granted that it
has an intention as theorists and critics,
we worry away at the question of how we can no attention.
And all of this is,
is,
is a dangerous mistake.
Uh,
because the fact is in everyday practice,
any piece of language we encountered,
we just assume to have an intention.
All right?
So they give us an example in which this assumption is tested and makes us
realize what's at stake in supposing that we know the meaning of something.
Ordinarily we just spontaneously say,
I know what that means.
Or if we don't know what it means,
ah,
it must mean something even though I don't know what it means.
That's,
I mean that,
that that's our normal approach to a piece of language.
But then I say,
I suppose you're working on the beach and you come across a four lines.
Um,
uh,
lines is already a dangerous thing to say.
Scratches in the sand that look an awful lot like the first stanza of
Wordsworth,
a slumber did my spirit seals lumber,
did my spirits seal.
I had no human fears.
She seemed a thing that could not feel the touch of human years of earthly
years.
There it is on the beach just right in front of us.
And we say,
Oh,
well somebody has come along,
some Wordsworth lover.
It's come along here and scratch these lines in the sand so that the intention
of the text is unquestioned.
Wordsworth wrote it.
Uh,
somebody now wants us to remind us of how of what a wonderful stands it is.
And there it is.
And of course it's very difficult to know what it means,
but at least I can ascribe meaning to it because no doubt,
you know,
it's an intended tech.
Whoa.
But then what happens?
Huge wave comes along and leaves on the beach underneath the first stanza.
The other stands up.
And,
and this,
and this of course is highly problematic.
Uh,
you know,
there it is.
No motion has she now no forest.
She neither here as nurses role round and earth star Arnold course with rocks
and stones and trees.
Now we're really puzzled maybe as APP and Michael say the sea is a kind of a
pantheistic being that likes to write poetry.
Uh,
you know,
so that the sea wrote it may the,
they say later on there are a little man in a submarine.
You know,
who,
uh,
look at their handiwork and say,
gee,
that was great.
Let's try that again.
Um,
in other words,
we can infer,
um,
all sorts of authors for the stanza,
but it's much more likely that instead of saying the sea writes poetry or
instead of saying they're a little sort of home monkey lie and submarines
writing poetry,
instead of saying that it's much more likely that we'll say,
this is an amazing coincidence,
truly amazing,
but it's just a coincidence.
What else could it be?
We'll set nab and Michael's his point,
which was the same point that you might,
that you might make about a parrot sang,
my boss is a jerk.
For example,
you know,
the parrot doesn't mean that you know,
the parent is the parent is just making words.
Somebody else met.
It may be,
but the parrot is,
you know,
that's just words for the parrot.
Okay.
Or monkeys at typewriters writing Shakespeare,
you know,
we're,
we're told that on given eternity,
this is a task that could be accomplished always.
Supposing somebody were there to whisk away the sheets whenever they wrote a
word and finally put it back together.
You know,
all of this,
uh,
these things are possibilities.
But we suddenly realized that those texts,
my boss is a jerk.
A slumber did a spirit seal written by chance,
by whatever it is.
And it's an already,
there's a sort of an intentionality and tail than the idea of writing by
something but just left by chance.
We suddenly realize according to an APP and Michael's,
that in that case,
those words are only like language.
They are not actually language because nobody wrote them,
nothing wrote the no entity or being from God on Don wrote them.
They are just there by chance.
Therefore,
even though they look like language,
we suddenly realized that it would be foolish to put,
to suppose that they have meaning.
I mean there is a poem that exactly resembles this bunch of marks that we see in
front of us,
and that poem has meaning,
but this bunch of marks does not have meaning.
Now,
I think probably most of us and I,
that's why I think in a way not,
but Michael's could have chosen a better example.
I think probably most of us would resist the idea that we can't interpret the
bunch of marks.
They're identical to language.
We should,
we feel free to interpret them after all.
Nobody knows what the poem means anyway.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's been the subject of critical controversy for decades.
That's one of the reasons nap and Michael's Jews it.
Um,
and so,
okay,
there it is on the beach.
I'll have my stab at it.
You know,
it must mean something.
So here it goes.
Uh,
and,
and so we resist that.
That's why I gave you this other example because it seems to me in a way,
the other example is more compelling than that nap and Michael's now you see
these two ladies looking up at the tree,
they upper,
what do you call them?
Boluses.
What,
what do you call those?
The branches sought off and eventually there's a kind of a scar forms.
What's,
what's what?
Pardon?
Burl.
Uh,
the upper burl
certainly looks an awful lot like Jesus.
And it was,
and these,
and,
and this went,
and when this appeared in Milford about 15 years ago,
um,
not just these two ladies,
but hundreds and hundreds of people visited the site.
Now they of course,
believed that that was on the tree because God put it there.
Therefore it had meaning.
We knew what it was.
It was a representation of the face of Jesus and,
and,
and the feeling that one could know what it was,
interpreted it,
take it to be an actual representation of something was there for unquestioned
as we would all agree.
You accept the premise,
God wrote it or I should say put it there.
Uh,
at at him he's been known to do the same thing with toasted cheese sandwiches
and Tacos and so,
and you know,
it happens,
right?
You,
you accept that premise and you're all set.
But suppose you say no,
no,
God didn't write that.
God didn't put that there.
It's just an accident.
Wouldn't you then say,
oh,
therefore it has no meaning.
It's not a representation of anything.
It just looks like something.
In other words,
in this case,
however you feel about a slumber,
did my spirits seal in this case you would accept nap and Michael's argument,
it would say it really does depend on the inference of an intention.
If I had,
if I infer no intention by ascribed no meaning,
if I infer an intention,
I ascribe meaning.
So nab and Michael's as simply making the same argument about a slumber did my
spirit's seal.
And I think it's a very strong argument.
You know,
once you realize,
or once I should say,
you accept the idea that meaning just his intention and think about it at
illogically.
When I say,
I mean that precisely means I intend.
All right.
It's not,
it doesn't quite work that way in all languages,
but it certainly works that way in English.
Uh,
and it's worth remembering to mean is too intense.
And so it makes a lot of sense to say that a meaning just is add intention and
that it's perhaps against the grain of common sense to factor them apart to say,
wow,
I could see,
ah,
you know,
I could see this sentence and I have a certain notion what it might mean,
but I still don't know what the author intended to say,
which is forbid from this standpoint a Napa and Michael's,
of course,
you know what the author intended to say.
You've just described meaning to the sentence.
Now mind you,
you may be wrong,
but that isn't to say that you're being wrong hinges on knowing what the author
intended in a certain sense app.
And Michael's a great,
perfectly well with the new critics.
And with Fuko or whoever it might be,
uh,
and say,
well,
you never know what an author intended.
Um,
that's not the point.
The meaning of the sentence in itself and tails intention.
If it weren't a sentence spoken intentionally by an agent,
human or otherwise,
it wouldn't have meaning because it wouldn't be language.
And in a certain sense,
this then can carry us to our second argument because having established in
their own minds satisfactorily the for any text,
the meaning of the text,
Joe must just be its intention.
In other words,
to be understood as language at all.
To repeat myself once again to be understood as language at all and intention
needs to be inferred.
The argument being,
you know,
we ought to be able to recognize supposing we succeed in not inferring and
intention that what we are looking at is actually not language.
It's just a simulacrum of language and effective copy of language.
Like for example,
the speech of a parrot or the words produced by monkeys on typewriters and so
on.
We should not from such Simulacra of words for not only intention but meaning as
well.
It is meaningless to speak of marks that are not signs
as language.
Okay,
bring us,
bringing us to the notion of sign for cs purse who actually discriminated among
hundreds of different kinds of sign.
All signs are active.
That is to say they have an agency,
they have a purpose,
they have a function purse in other words,
does not understand them as as the in the way that so sewer does as being
differential of,
he understands that too.
But for him,
the central point about assign is it's is,
is the agency of the sign.
All right.
Now the implication of this is clear and it's the application that nap and
Michael's draw on in this argument.
Their claim is that there is no distinction to be made between language and
speech.
Now first,
not now.
Let's just pause over their argument.
And I would think the fact that as we think about that,
especially since we've been exposed to so sewer and,
and,
and I and I hope have come to accept the idea that language is a virtual sin,
chronic,
uh,
entity laid out in space and speech is an actual diachronic performance derived
from language laid out in time.
Right?
Since we have absorbed that and since we just have this sort of spontaneous,
if we're students of literary theory,
a belief that there is a distinction between language and speech,
what do we do when we come face to face with this claim of nap and Michael's
now,
I think that they make,
they make their most effective case in a footnote.
This is the last footnote I'll be calling your attention to this semester.
Uh,
and it's like all footnotes,
uh,
perhaps the most telling thing in the essay,
and it appears on page oh eight.
Oh,
I can't,
I find it on a piece on page oh eight four.
Footnote number 12,
not going to read the whole thing and just going to read a single sentence.
Uh,
at the top on page 21 footnote 12,
which they say a dictionary is an index of frequent usages in particular speech
acts,
not a matrix of abstract pre intentional possibilities.
Think about that language we're suppose is an addition to being,
uh,
a set of Greg grammatical and syntactical rules.
Also a set of definitions made available for speech acts.
That's that,
that is the assumption that of course,
and literary theory provides for us nothing.
Michael's are denying that in this footnote there saying that dictionary
definitions are just a sum total as it were,
of words in action that any definition is of a word which is already a speech
act.
Oed,
you go through all 18 definitions of a word.
There are all of them,
uh,
embedded in sentences.
Speech acts and can be taken out of sentences,
uh,
and still understood in their agency as performed any word in a dictionary and
other words according to tea to nap.
And Michaels is a word performed and the record,
a fossilized as it were in the dictionary is a record,
not have meaning per se,
but of performance of the way and what's the word works in speech in history.
And so a dictionary is nothing other than a composite or some total of speech
acts.
And to distinguish therefore between language as something which is pre action
and speech,
which is the implementation of language as a mistake language even in the sense
that it's always there before us is nevertheless always active.
It is a record of those actions that have taken place before our own actions as
speakers.
There's no difference between me acting through speech and language preexisting
as something which is not action.
It's all continuous as an ever deepening,
broadening and self complicating record of action or speech action.
Now this is a very interesting idea.
Uh,
and I think again,
it's an idea that one might well go along way a long way with,
I think it should be said in defensive.
So sir,
by the way,
that in a certain way he anticipates this position.
Remember I told you that although for purposes of learning to understand
structuralism and its aftermath,
we only distinguish between language and speech long and powerful.
But in,
so sir,
there's actually a third category I sort of intermediate category,
which he calls long gosh and long gosh is actually the sum total of all known
speech acts.
If you could godify or or,
or quantify everything that's ever been said or written,
that would be long gone.
As you can see how it's different from long,
which needn't necessarily ever have been said at all.
I'll be coming back to that in a minute.
A long gosh,
in other words is empirical as nap.
And Michael's would say it is something that had we enough information we could
actually codify into a vast database.
It would be the sum of all speech acts and that actually what's so circle as
long gosh would be not unlike what Napa and Michael's mean by language.
You see,
so so,
so Sarah is aware that you can think of the some of speech act in the way that
Napa and Michael's do,
but he still holds out for this other category.
This,
this,
this notion of long,
uh,
as,
the code from which speech acts are derived,
uh,
as a thing apart.
Now,
I think as I say,
um,
this is a persuasive position because after all,
as long as we suppose that language exists for communication,
that it is interactive as long as we accept as we have accepted from Bactine and
others during the course of the course,
as long as we set,
except the idea that language is social,
that all of events deployments,
um,
our interactive,
uh,
derived from the speech acts of others,
appropriated for oneself as one's own set of speech acts influential on yet
other people as a speech act,
as long as we accept this we say to ourselves.
Yeah.
And it makes a lot of sense to think of language as inseparable from speech,
uh,
to think of language simply as the sum of all agencies.
Uh,
so that no meaningful distinction between that,
some of agencies and that in the Individual Agency of a speech act,
uh,
needs to be made
notice though.
And here by the way,
is where I'm going to make my turn and save theory.
So,
okay,
sharpen your pencils.
Um,
notice that I began that last riff by saying,
as long as we suppose language exists for communication,
now we do suppose language exists for communication.
I mean,
what else could it exist for?
what do we do with language except to communicate?
Uh,
you know,
you could say,
well,
we write doodles,
we make meaningless marks in the sand.
There are all kinds of things.
Maybe we do a language,
but let's face it,
we don't,
right?
If I,
if I do in fact make marks in the sand amounting to Islamic did by spirits seal
it,
it's because I love Wordsworth has,
by the way,
I do.
And I wish to communicate love to the rest of the world.
You know,
I mean,
it's a speech act.
Come on,
I'm not just making marks.
If I wanted to make marks,
I'd do,
you know,
I'd do something,
but rather more mark like,
well,
so,
so in any case,
in any case,
um,
we certainly inhabit a life world in which it is almost inconceivable for anyone
to come along and tell us language is not for the purpose of communication.
In other words,
napping,
Michael seemed to be completely right.
What else is it for?
I mean,
you know,
I mean that's what we use it for.
We have refined it,
uh,
to a fare thee well as an efficient,
flexible,
sometimes even eloquent medium,
medium of communication.
That's what language is for.
That's what it exists for.
And as I'm saying,
if we accept this idea,
which seems simply to carry the day because who could think anything else?
If we accept this idea,
then there's a very strong case for napping.
Michael's being right really,
there no significant or important difference between language and speech.
But now suppose we approached the question from a,
I don't say from an empirical,
you know,
because
from a speculative anthropological point of view in other,
but suppose we approached it,
but with some,
with some rather common sense remarks.
Now we say language is for communication.
The purpose of language is for communication.
We say that.
Now does that mean especially if we think of the whole history of mankind,
does that mean that the purpose of fire is for cooking
in other words or to bring it a little bit closer to home?
It doesn't mean that the purpose of the prehensile thumb is for grasping
doesn't mean that the purpose of a cave,
a hole in the rock is for dwelling.
No.
In those cases,
adaptation is what makes fire a good thing to cook with the prehensile thumb.
A good thing to grasp with.
And a cave,
a good thing to take shelter in.
But they all,
and there are various ways are just,
they're plainly,
all of them have other,
well not purposes because the purpose is is when you think about it only
something that we can impose on something,
but they certainly aren't out there in any sense for us to do the thing that it
turns out we,
we've decided it's a good idea to do with it,
you know,
great,
fire burns us but what we can cook with it,
you know,
and,
and so on.
Now in the case of language,
in the case of language,
we have to suppose as a matter of fact,
that language as it were,
appears among us and the same way that the prehensile thumb did,
of course we discovered its use.
But that's a funny way to put it.
Might be more circumspect to say that we discovered it had a use for us,
which was to communicate.
And so once we were able to put this,
whatever it was,
this,
this weird capacity to make differential sounds,
uh,
once we put this weird capacity to make differential sounds to work,
hence forth for us and for our purposes,
language was to communicate.
And of course we made an enormous success of it or a tower of Babel of it,
which whichever you prefer to think.
But in any case we have it.
Uh,
and it has developed among us as a means or medium of communication.
But you know,
I mean if,
uh,
in whatever by whatever mute unsee a language arose opposing this to be the
case.
And,
and you know,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not making an argument that has anything to do with intelligent design one
way or another.
So pausing supposing that by whatever mute and see,
um,
language appeared and that of course the next day there were an avalanche.
Alright.
It might well be the case that the space is a consisting of all of us sitting in
this room and I guess a few other people that,
that,
that this space is a might be mute.
It might be communicating perhaps with incredible eloquence,
perhaps even with literary genius by means of signs or who knows,
or for that matter it might have taken a detour and its development.
So that's that communication was not anything one could identify as specifically
human.
Uh,
Paul,
all sentient beings communicate.
Uh,
but it's possible that this particular species could have taken a turn in its
development,
uh,
after which communication was much as it is among mice or,
or,
or whatever.
Uh,
all of this is possible.
You'll see why don't we think about language,
a property that we have and manipulate and communicate with.
Uh,
anthropologically it comes into being in such a way that it is,
I would think scarcely relevant to say that its purpose is for communication.
It comes into being simply as an attribute,
a property,
something we happen to have something someone happens to have four,
which a use is then discovered as for fire,
for the prehensile thumb and for the cave.
I mean the relationship between the cave and the house.
It seems to me as a particularly interesting way of thinking about the
relationship between language as a set of differential.
So and notice something about the signs of language.
And here of course we also invoke so cert,
so sir lays every stress on the idea that language is made up of differential
and arbitrary signs and other assessor denies that there's such a thing in
language as a natural sign.
In other words,
the and the Russian formalists do this as well.
Both.
So Sir and the Russian formalists warn us against believing that automotive
poetic devices,
peep,
devices like that are actually natural signs that they are derived.
In other words from the thing in the world that they seem through their sound to
represent.
So Sir reminds us that these are acts accidents of edible logical history,
which can also be understood in adaptive terms.
Automotive Pia exists in language because it's good for communication and it's
fun to communicate with,
but it doesn't enter language as a natural sign.
It only passes through moments in the,
in the evolution of a given word,
it only passes through woman's in which the relationship between the sound and
the thing represented seems to be natural.
This is a matter upon which great stress is late both for,
so sir and for the Russian formalists you may,
you may have thought when you read these,
these passages in which such dresses laid on it,
you may have thought,
well that's overkill.
Them cares about anema pay.
What does that have to do with it?
It anchors the entire idea about language,
which is precisely that.
It is something other than speech.
When we speak,
we not only endeavored to communicate,
we endeavor to refer.
In other words,
we take language and we try to make it as the philosophers say,
hook on to the natural world.
We take a set of signs,
a code which is not in itself natural,
which is arbitrary.
And through the sheer force of will we make those signs as best we can hook on
to the natural,
to the actual world.
And in doing so,
we reinforce the idea that language is for communication.
Whereas my argument is language isn't for communication.
Speech is when we speak that is entirely and exclusively and without any other
motive for communication except for one thing that the Russian formalists in
particular it took note of.
There are funny things going on and going on in our speech,
alliteration,
unnecessary or uneconomical forms of repetition,
weird things going on in a nurse in our speech,
which don't seem to have the purpose of communication.
As a matter of fact,
they actually seem to impede communication.
You know,
if I,
you know,
when I,
when when I really started messing language up,
you know,
twas Brillig and the slide the toes did gyre and Gimble in the way when I really
started messing language up,
I'm really,
I'm impeding communication because I'm laying stress on elements of rhythm,
pattern,
sound recurrence,
uh,
which cannot be said to have any direct bearing on communication.
And this of course is what we've studied recurrently.
And I have to say empirically because these are all empirical facts about
language as as the Russian formalists insisted,
you know what we have studied recurrently is the way in which language rears its
ugly head in speech,
the way in which in other words,
language won't be repressed as mere communication,
the way in which speech and tails elements that keep bubbling up to the surface
and asserting themselves,
which oddly enough really can't be said to conduce to communication and those
things,
those elements that bubble up to the surface are nothing other than the that
evidence of the presence of language precisely in the way that in Freud,
the Freudian slip,
the fact that I can't get through a sentence without making some kind of blunder
some and very often an embarrassing blunder for in Freud the Freudian slip is
understood as the bubbling up into conscious.
The conscious effort to speak of that which speech cat control of that which
Freud calls the unconscious and which by the way,
we would have no idea of the existence of if it weren't for the Freudian slip.
In other words,
we,
as Freud said in the first handout that I gave you at the beginning of the
semester,
we infer the unconscious from the behavior of consciousness because given the
nature of the behavior of consciousness,
it seems necessary to do so by precisely the same token.
We can't and I think should say we infer language as something else from the
composite or a sum total as speed of speech acts.
We infer language from the erratic behavior of speech because it seems there is
no other way to account for the erratic behavior of speech.
That sense of language,
which I'm going to be talking a lot more about on Thursday.
That sense of language sort of bubbling up and it beat from below in speech and
proving its existence as something other than a composite record of all speeches
is what suggests to us that nap and Weigel's,
uh,
are not quite right in saying there's really no difference between language and
speech.
And if there's really an,
if there is a difference between language and speech as I'm claiming and if the
difference between language and speech is much as we have talked to think of it
by.
So Sir and his success successes down through deconstruction.
If there is such a difference,
then guess what?
We have literary theory back in the fold alive and well.
And we no longer have to say that it should be jettisoned from our thinking
about literature.
We have a real use for literary theory,
but that's exactly where Napa and Michael supposing supposing they were here and
I'd convince them.
And by the way,
I know them both.
You can't convince them of anything,
but that's not unusual.
You probably can't convince me of anything either.
Um,
uh,
suppose,
suppose we had them here and I had succeeded in convincing them,
they would say,
well,
okay,
but isn't it a pity because you have proved better than I could.
That literary theory has no purpose.
You know,
why on earth should we worry about all this bubbling up of,
of stuff that has nothing to do with communication after all,
we're here to communicate,
aren't we?
We've begun by saying that our life world consist precisely in the deployment of
language for communication.
And here's this person saying this is stuff bubbling up.
You know what I mean?
Which,
which,
which makes communication difficult.
You know,
what use is that Knipe nap.
And Michael's might say,
you'll see they are pragmatists,
aren't they?
Right?
They are,
they are a pragmatist or niche.
They are concerned with practicality,
their interests,
their,
their reason for being interested in meaning and interpretation is a practical
reading.
It reason entirely and tailed in the understanding of communication and the
furtherance of communication,
whereas theory,
which I have saved,
I nevertheless seem to have saved at a pretty considerable cost because I have
suggested that theory itself is completely impractical and all I've suggested
it,
we're going to get back to that next time.
That's what the Thursday lecture is going to be going to be about.
Um,
but in the meantime,
you say to yourself,
okay,
fine,
we've got theory,
but we've also been shown that you can't really do anything with it.
Um,
and so,
uh,
it might just as well,
um,
sued us to suppose that nap and Michael's are right.
Uh,
and to proceed as though theory could be jettisoned.
Um,
one last quick point,
going back to the distinction between meaning and intention.
Notice the two pronged argument.
On the one hand,
people like Ed Hirsch who believe that you can invoke an author's intention in
order to pin down a meaning.
On the one hand,
you have people like that.
And on the other hand,
you have people doing deconstruction who say that because there is no inferable
intention,
texts themselves have no meaning.
That's not quite right,
because that's not what really what deconstruction says.
Deconstruction doesn't say,
texts have no meaning.
Deconstruction doesn't even say that.
You can't know what the meaning of a text is.
Exactly.
What deconstruction says is that you can't rope off meaning in a text.
Text have too much meaning.
Texts explode with meaning.
You can't corral the way in which texts,
uh,
produce meaning.
You can't corral corral at by inferring an intention.
You can't corral Corel.
It by taking a particular interpretive path,
meaning just explodes in texts.
That's not at all the same thing as to as,
as to say,
uh,
according to the claim of Napa and Michael's that in deconstructive thinking
texts have no meaning of very,
very different proposition altogether.
And I think it might suggest to you that the relationship between intention and
meaning isn't really what's at stake in deconstruction.
A text is intended or you can say,
well,
it may be intended,
uh,
no doubt it's intended all sorts of ways of putting it.
But is that really the point?
The text is the text on this view and the text just as I say,
fairly bristles with meaning that being precise to the point you can't reign it
in.
That's not really the flip side as nap.
And Michael's would,
would,
would want to make you think.
It's not really the flip side of the idea,
uh,
of the followers of Hirsch,
that in order to know a meaning,
you have to be able to infer an authorial intention.
There's no symmetry there.
Uh,
and as I say,
I'm not sure that deconstruction,
whatever its claims,
whatever it's perfections and imperfections,
I'm not sure that really deconstruction has the question of intention in
relation to meaning very much at heart one way or another.
Sorry to have kept you.
We'll see you Thursday.